it is a nefarious fact for the communities
means death the coal for us
as well as there generates light here does not generate
the darkness we live in that darkness
for giving light to other countries
we were rich because we had a
extreme communion with mother earth the
intimate relationship was deep now in
these moments we do not have any
relationship we have a relationship with an evil
neighbor that we have here that does not pollute
and he cerrejón
my name is jasmine rosemary epiayú good
My name is Angelica Ortiz
I am a coordinator in the organization
force Wayúu women who are the
movement force women we are women
activists directly from the
communities
more of rhythms so that you look for one is
expert in the community fits very
all right
wade dawn and I swear there are people in
I would take home since there are
towers caire catramina kazakhstan and
playstation store
It is a statue
mariachi and they no longer have a house in wenchuán
japan and guam taiwan marijuana helps
taiwan to mine in canine gp and we do not
case in doing the same way close
genetically does not originate the same
swear to improve the eyebrow
since on August 9, 2001 we were of
that returned from our town to blood
and ground fire acquired in its 30 years
no sanction for violation of any
law or love process some
procedure we follow what the state
orders us to follow and invest resources
very superior in those who and through
any other company in this country in
matter of social responsibility
We regret that you do not have any
recognition from you
two
they are initiated by withdrawing education
health the water is taking off well
the electrification is removed
electricity to energy to people
so that he leaves his community and they leave
to live better because I previously lived
in a mud house that they now live in
citadels or in populated centers
urbanized with all the finishes that
they had us before
here is another house they have the chickens
thing that in the new place of the
urbanization the houses are not going to
can have
where to create a hen
will not be
not taking into account that in that house of
mud they had secured their three meals
daily because they were hunting because
they were fishing because they were raising
animals with those that were for their
support and for the study of their
children too
in front
he has all his life tell me that
land did not leave a note let's go blessing
people around here vote
here there is no doctor here there is no school
here there is not even the bus because the
recipe is removed
takes lacking water
of light but we are still understanding
we had taken from here
in beijing music sound
because these consumer countries do not
they exploit their own coal in their country
because they have to come to explode
coal in Latin America because because o
be because they have to change the life
for by the materialism title purchases and
if you put money to buy coal
of colombia is contributing to the
disappearing from the communities and by
the same the death of the communities
then they kill us all and that
exploit all resources because everything
this coal